that's a great question I I can tell you
this that on day
one I'm going to issue a uh executive
order to all federal
employees um making it uh a firing
offense to collaborate with media to
censor political speech in this country
social media or
media and that would apply to the CIA
the FBI DHS and all of the agencies we
now know from the Twitter files and
other sources including my litigation
you know which is in the Supreme Court
right now Kennedy versus Biden and
Missouri versus Biden we know from
Discovery in those that they were
collaborating with about with over a
dozen agencies to censor political
speech in this country